[Music]
Hey folks, I am Anushut. I lead the
applied research team here at PromQL. Uh
PromQL you might have seen is the
sponsor for the reliability track here
at the AI engineers worldwide. Uh so
today I'll talk about um that data
readiness is a myth. How many of you are
trying to deploy some kind of AI system
on some kind of data in a production
environment?
Okay. Awesome. Who are who is trying to
work with more than like documents and
vector databases?
Okay. Is whose data is perfect? Clean,
annotated, perfect column names, table
names, anyone see no hands. Okay. So,
and how much time does everyone like
Okay, I'm not going to ask make this a
question. You all spend a lot of time uh
making your data ready, right? So that
the AI can understand it. So that the AI
understands the meanings and the
relationships in your data. But it's
just a pipe dream that we are all
chasing, right? We are all chasing this
perfect data dream so that our AI can
finally work reliably on it and that's
never going to happen. So how do we
still make reliable on no matter how
messy data we have? Okay. So tell me if
this is a fact is this what your data
looks like. Your uh that's how you name
your tables. That's what how you name
your columns. Sometimes they have null
values. Sometimes you have old values
old column names. Sometimes yes shortand
cst_n does that customer name is it
custom nomomenclature I don't know what
that is uh rev_amount_usd
that's how you name your revenue is
active now is this binary is it boolean
field is it zero one true false null not
null I don't know what it is right then
you have other system that's just one
system one table in one system you have
other system which have similar things
right it has organization name it has
total revenue how does that map to your
other systems, right? Is the revenue in
cents? Is it in dollars, decimal value,
floating points? What is it? Right? You
have no idea. Okay? So, in 2019,
everyone was saying, "Let's standardize
everything. Move everything in
snowflake. Let's move everything in data
bricks and finally your problems will be
fixed." 40% complete. Uh MDM will fix
this. Master data management team will
fix this. That's their responsibility.
They're still implementing their
solution. So in 2023 with the rise of
AI, rise of agents, we'll we'll create
semantic layers that understand our uh
data domain. I mean breaks every
quarter. Your data domain changes every
quarter, right? You change your tables,
you change your schemas, you change your
uh workflows. So in 2025, we saying AI
needs perfect data to work and it's
still waiting and it's never going to
happen, right? And McKenzie said that on
an average a fortune 500 company loses
$250 million because of poor data
quality.
So how do we fix this? U who has tried
playing with semantic layers mem zero at
semantic kernel you have tried playing
with it right? How has your experience
been?
Okay.
Okay. Gotcha.
Lot of pruning. Okay. And I'm assuming
you're manually adding information to
it, maintaining it and stuff like that,
right? Sure.
Yeah. Uh okay. So let's say you have
added a definition like customer
acquisition cost means marketing spend
divided by new customers. Okay. Now this
is some information your AI needs to
answer your questions. But that's not
enough right? Like what which marketing
spend coming from the brand team from
the performance team? What does a new
customer even mean? Right? First
purchase purchase customer reactivated
customer for what time period are we
talking about? Does it include failed
trials or not? Uh does is it accounting
for seasonality? There's so many things
that you need to do and you can never
capture all of that in a semantic layer
just by if you think you can manually
add everything you can't. Right? So you
can't predefine uh every edge case.
Knowledge graphs. Who's played with
knowledge graphs? Graph rag heard of it
at least. Okay. A bunch of people. Okay.
Awesome. So uh let's take a very simple
example. Assume a customer's uh assume a
sales data set uh where you have defined
this graph that deals mapped to stage a
date and an owner. Okay. And a very
simple question I ask show me deals at
risk. Right? Very simple questions. The
graph knows that deals map to stages,
stages mapped to close dates. But what
does at risk mean? Is it mean that the
champion has just left? Is it mean it
has been stuck in that stage for two
months? Like what does at risk mean to
my business? Right? How do you capture
that in a graph database? Right? How do
you capture a billion rows of snowflake
table in a uh graph database? You can't.
So graph is also not the sol. Knowledge
graph is also not the solution. So the
real problem here is not that we need we
we need a better semantic layer
solution. We need a better graph rack
solution. We need a and like better
named database systems. No, the problem
is that the AI does not speak your
business business's language. Like a GM
in a finance domain can mean gross
margin but in a HR domain might mean
general manager, right? What does
conversion mean to you? What does
quarter mean to you? What does the
definition of your quarter? I'll show
you an example uh here with an AI system
not working with that. And uh what is
what is what is an active customer?
Every team has their own definition,
right? So, how does an AI speak this
tribal knowledge, this tacet knowledge
that you have developed while being in
your company for so many years, right?
Your AI does not know that. Your vanilla
LLMs don't know that. They're super
smart, incredible at doing so many cool
stuff, uh, so much cool stuff, but they
don't understand your business, your
domain, right? So, traditionally, we had
these analysts, these engineers, right?
Whenever a a business user or a customer
had a problem, had a task, they had a
question, um they would go to this
analyst or an engineer who knew about
the business, who had this tribal
knowledge in their head. They knew how
to write code, SQL, whatever. They can
talk to your underlying data systems.
SQL, no SQL, doesn't matter. Any kind of
data source, right? And they have this
tribal knowledge which they use to
answer your question with 100%
reliability. They explain what they're
doing, right? And that's how you have
all built trust in your colleagues in
your uh peers right that's what is
missing with AI right this this tribal
knowledge piece that doesn't exist today
with AI and that's the
problem so the solution the same
semantic layer but let's make it aic
what that means is let's not try to
improve it let's not try to manually add
context there continuously no how about
we make an AI system that behaves It's
like an analyst you just hired today.
Day one, day zero, the analyst comes to
your company, super smart, can do a
bunch of things, doesn't know a lot
about your business yet. They start
working with you. They mess up
somewhere. You tell them, "No, no,
that's not what you should have done.
This is what I mean when I say this." It
learns, learns, learns, learns. Now,
this analyst 10 years later is an
experienced analyst in your company.
They know everything about your
business. Right? Let's make an AI like
that. An AI that keeps improvement,
keeps learning as you use it more and
more, as you course correct it, as you
steer it. But assumption is your AI
needs to be correctable, explainable,
steerable, already accurate in what it
knows. Right? So let's see how you build
such an AI. Right? So we're trying to
replace this human part of the AI,
right? So that's what we have been
trying to do with promql. It's like a
day zero smart analyst, right? So we
take a foundational LM and that's the
whatever LM you bring. We make it create
promql plans. PromQL is basically a
domain specific language which can do
three tasks data retrieval, data compute
aggregation and semantics
and this is a deterministic domain
language and vanilla elements are
incredible at generating we don't have
to fine-tune them right now within this
DSL I can ask the LM to create this DSL
whenever I ask user asks a question now
I can execute this DSL in a
deterministic runtime I do not involve
the LM in actual execution, actual
generation of an answer because if I let
the LM generate the answer, it's by
default hallucinating and I'm just
hoping the hallucination is correct.
That's how LM work, right? So I'm saying
decouple it. Let the LLM generate the
plan and we will execute this plan in a
deterministic runtime and let it work on
a distributed query engine which will
talk to the different data sources, pull
out the data, do whatever composition
was required inside that DSL, show the
answer directly to the user. Don't give
it back to the LM. Let's not do rag,
right? Let's not give the ele data back
to the LM and let make it generate the
answer, right? That's what uh the promul
design is. Let me show you promul
working in action. Uh I have five
minutes so let's make this quick. Simple
question. Uh who are my top five
customers by revenue? You'll be like any
AI system can answer that question dude.
It's a simple text to SQL question.
Okay. So promul is like first of all it
understands what revenue means. Revenue
means your invoice items. Okay, cool.
Uh, I'll do do the math. Execute the
math. And here are your top five
customers. Oops. Nope. I didn't notice
we did not get any results, right?
That's what a smart analyst does in
their first attempt. They realized they
messed up somewhere. Okay, I see the
issue now. We're looking for succeeded
status, but the actual statuses are paid
and pending. See, your data is messy. It
did not know what was happening, right?
It figured that out, and now these are
your top five based on the actual data
that's under the hood. So that's
possible. Let's run this query now.
Okay. Find the unique customers we
serve. The c org ID data is messed up.
So don't use that. Find unique orgs
based on the email domains of the
individual users. Then find the org with
the third highest revenue. I'll I'll let
that run because uh it'll take time. Uh
find the unique orgs based on the email
domains of the individual users. Then
for the org with the third highest
revenue, take a look at the latest 30
support tickets. So multiple database
then your Zenesk support system
including the comments on those tickets.
Then summarize each ticket. Then use
those summaries and extract their
feelings towards our product. Create
five categories from bad to great and
then tell me what is going well, what
what can be improved and then issue up
to $5,000 to this orgs project as like
credits with the highest usage. Uh which
means 5,000 if they're feeling is bad
towards us and 1,000 if it's great
towards us. Now, how do you think an AI
can do this? Spread across your
databases, your SAS application like
Zenesk, your uh API like Stripe to issue
the credit, stuff like that. It's like,
okay, cool. First, I'll get all the
users, extract their email domains. See,
this is an analyst explaining their
thought process. You see that tiny uh
pencil icon? I can edit their brain. I
can tell them, "No, this is not what I
wanted you to do. Don't do step three.
Instead of that, do these three steps
instead." Right? I can I can be in
charge of my AI but still every single
time if I have to nudge my AI the AI is
going to learn the AI will understand
okay that's what you wanted me to do
makes sense that's how you do your
business I didn't know that sorry I'll
learn now right so okay cool I should
have said can just show me intermediate
results step by step but anyway um it
says I'm about to issue $3,000 refund
probably it got a neutral sentiment from
it um and see it's exactly what's
happening it's saying I got the top five
domains by revenue.
This is the sentiment. I summarized a
bunch of tickets. I classified,
extracted the sentiment out of that. And
then finally, I'm figuring out what is
happening there. Um, okay.
So, credit to show details. Perfect.
Based on analysis, Peter Thompson. Third
highest revenue customer with this much
in revenue, sentiment analysis, decent
of tickets, blah blah blah. See, this AI
just woke that analyst as an analyst
with such a complicated prompt. So now
let's look back at the learning right
just because we are at two and a half
minutes. Okay. So that's day zero. Day
zero it had to figure stuff out figure
it out did did well. Day X once it's
become a better analyst right it has
learned a bunch. Let me make this bigger
for you. Uh learned a bunch right. So as
it's using as you're working with it
right it learns from it. This is a
prompt learning layer which basically
improves the semantic graph and starts
creating your company's business
language. this acmeql acme I assume it's
a name of a company right and now
suddenly promql becomes acmeql which
becomes googleql microsoft appleql
ciscoql whatever company you come from
right and I'll show you that learning
process in action okay so this is an
example where I have purposefully named
my tables extremely bad right and I ask
a question which employees are working
in departments with more than us dollars
$10,000 budget okay it says I have no
idea what we're talking about your data
says there are three tables called morg
plug and zorp. I have no idea what that
means. I can't answer your question. I'm
like no worries. Can you sample a few
rows from each table and figure out what
table contains the employees like cool?
That's what I tell man. Let's go figure
it out. Right? It's like okay now I see
zorb contains employee information. Plug
contains department information and mor
is like a junction table that you have.
Okay. So now this is your answer that
you were asking for. And I'm like okay
but the data is in cents not in dollars.
The budget is in cents. So can you
divide by 100 please and give me the
right answer now there shouldn't be five
employees it says cool there are two
employees right perfect now this is um
uh this is manual but this also runs
genetically in the background where all
I have to do is suggest metadata
improvements based on the recent threads
right look at what have we spoken about
how much I had to guide you whatever uh
hints I had to give you learn from it
and improve your semantic layer right
it's like Cool. So based on the
interaction that we have now I have this
improved semantic layer whereas like
okay zorp and plug are two tables I need
to add a lot more context to it in my
own
semantic layer right and the department
budget is in sense right cool apply the
suggestion every single instance of your
semantic layer is version controlled so
a new build is created you can always
fall back to a previous build and now
the next time as generated by autograph
that's what he calls the feature and the
next time I ask the same question which
employees are working in departments
with more than US $10,000 in budget. It
creates the right plan and I get the
right answer.
Right? So same if I had to say something
like this uh find accounts um with the
maximum suspicious anti-moneyaundering
outgoing amounts for the first quarter
for each print the account ID and name.
Right? If I let my AI do this. Okay, the
internet is a little bad, but um I have
this thread pre-loaded here. Okay, so it
gives me the answer and then I'm like,
no, the my quarter starts in February,
not in January. So, you should know
that, right? So, I just tell it this
time. Next time, the semantic layer
learns from it exactly the same way as
it'll infer the meanings of these
tables. It'll find the relationships
across your tables, right? And finally
with all of this what you have is
day zero your AI does not know what an
enterprise customer means. It does not
know how to match customer ids across
systems. It does not know what your
financial quart when your financial
quarter starts. Day 30 it has figured
out 47 business terms. It has mapped
relationships across the six systems. It
has discovered 12 calculation variants
and 100% accurate on your complex tasks.
That's what an agentic semantic layer
allows you to do. So reduces months of
work into immediate start like just
deploy your AI today. Let your AI start
working on your data. Let it improve
itself. No wait time, no lag time with
your AI deployments, right? It's
self-improving and gets to 100%
accuracy. Uh that's what we've been
hearing from our customers. It's a
Fortune 500 food chain company. They
evaluated 100 vendors. They realized no
none of them work. Finally they saw
PromQL and it worked 100% reliable AI.
Same with a high high growth fintech
company on their hardest questions we
were able to demonstrate 100% accuracy.
So try it reach out to us if you have
these big problems that you want to
solve and you want 100% accurate AI on
top of that. Uh we there for you. Thank
you.
[Music]